22h40 la forêt continue spécial
élections régionales sur france 3 en
bourgogne et en franche comté avec est
de nouveau invités qu'ils nous ont
rejoints en direct françois sauvadet
bonsoir bonsoir chef de file pour lr udi
et tête de liste donc en côte-d'or
également cécile prud'hommes bonsoir
dont son chef de file europe ecologie
les verts l'estimation vous rappelle
cette estimation pour la bourgogne
franche comté ipsos soprin steria
oui avec le front national qui
arriverait en tête avec 30 2,2 pour cent
des suffrages devant elle est rude et i
avec 24 2% à des voix le ps se place en
troisième position 21,7 et puis
précisons puisqu'il ya cécile
prud'hommes sur le plateau qu'europe
écologie les verts ne dépasserait pas
les 5% serait plutôt autour des 4% un
résultat définitif pour le département
de la côte d'or nous allons découvrir
ensemble ou la liste elle est rude et y
arrive en tête des suffrages avec un peu
plus de 30% devant le front national
27,7 le ps avec 22,3 la liste de maxime
thibeault debout la france et à 4,3 pc
pg mrc 4,1 3,7 pour europe ecologie les
verts le modem de christophe kugler est
à 3% l'alliance écologiste indépendante
à 2,1 1% 1,3 pour la liste lutte
ouvrière et charles-henri gallois pour
l'upm est à 0,7 pour cent la côte-d'or
votre département françois sauvadet où
vous arrivez donc en tête et vos limites
en quelque sorte la casse sur la
bourgogne franche comté
oui satisfaction pour vous arrivé en
tête mais aussi satisfait de voir que
partout en france un bourgogne franche
comté le le front national arrive en
tête
non assurément non donc on le voit bien
d'abord une blood responsabilité du
parti socialise les entend aujourd'hui
s'exprimer et dire raffault faut qu'on
prenne en compte tout ça enfin
franchement des réformes qu'on a eus
successives qui ont désorienté le monde
rural le chômage endémique qui sait les
promesses qui n'ont été pas été tenues
tout ça crée un climat et sans compter
tragédie que nous avons vécu sur lequel
le front national incontestablement à
surfer donc le ps tu pas s'exonérer de
ses responsabilités maintenant je mesure
la mienne particulièrement parce que
arrive en deuxième position
moi j'invite vraiment 2 ce soir les
abstentionnistes ce qu'ont voulu
adresser un message d'exaspération de
colère que je comprends et que j'ai
entendu je les invite à voter utile pour
que ça change parce que je n'ai pas plus
en voie d envie de voir le front
national arrivé au pouvoir en bourgogne
franche comté vous imaginez madame
ont-elles aux manettes de la région
alors que ça va nous engager pour six
ans
et puis je n'ai pas eu envie d'ailleurs
du retour du ps qui a échoué gravement
depuis onze ans
donc évidemment moi je m'adresse à tous
les abstentionnistes à tous ceux qui ont
voté leur disant voter utile au second
tour s'il voulait un vrai changement
eh bien nous pouvons nous devons
incarner ensemble et je t'en as salaires
les électeurs ne pouvaient avec
justement sophie montel depuis besançon
qui est donc sa fille monte elle est
tête de liste du front national qui est
aux côtés de catherine ainslie
alors ce film ont-elles une réaction
déjà à ce score vous pensez bien arrivé
en tête dans les départements mais pas
forcément avec cet écart de voix
je suis ravi de constater ce soir que la
dynamique les portées par le front
national elle est très bien portées par
le front national puisque comme vous
l'avez dit l'écart est très important
avec la liste udc les républicains et
encore plus avec la liste soutenue par
le parti socialiste pour le deuxième
tour vous allez les trouver ou vos voix
à écouter je crois que d'abord on a on à
la dynamique très de manière à contester
nous avons le front national se porte la
dynamique ce soir ils la portent
d'ailleurs des vues encore 18 points
pour pouvoir remporter cette région mais
attendez de voir qui je pense que ce
soit monsieur sauvadet ou madame du fai
vont se vaut se maintenir donc nous
serons dans le cadre donc cellulaire
youri ces deux candidats se maintiennent
donc nous serons bien dans le cadre
d'une triangulaire et donc avec l'écart
de voix conséquents que nous avons déjà
obtenu au soir de ce premier tour nous
avons effectivement une réserve de voix
aussi chez les abstentionnistes nous
avons une réserve de voix
chez les électeurs de debout la france
nous avons une réserve de voix chez les
syndicats ça veut dire quoi que vous
fait un appel du pied à maxime thébaux
la tête de liste régionale l appel du
pied à personne j'appelle moi tout
simplement les patriotes de droite comme
de gauche à se rassembler autour du seul
mouvement qui incarne cette rupture avec
le système ump est ce parce que quand
j'entends monsieur sauvadet parler de la
gestion calamiteuse de madame du fait je
l'invite à regarder la gestion de son
département de côte-d'or
les français ne sont plus dupes je
ressens donc genre à celle pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas la politique
régionale sur le bout des doigts que
françois sauvadet le président du
conseil départemental de côte-d'or du
donc c'était et accessoirement monsieur
sauvadet a fait exploser les impôts
locaux en côte d'or il a fait exploser
la dette
il a fait baisser de manière absolument
vertigineuse les dépenses
d'investissement alors que les dépenses
de fonctionnement elles ont augmenté de
manière caricaturale
donc voyez si vous voulez le ce soir je
pense que les français ont envoyé un
message très clair à la clique ump s en
disant ça suffit le changement veut le
changement et le changement est incarné
par le français réagissent à ce ballet à
vos propos et j'ai bien vu j'ai bien vu
les critiques adressées à la gestion
mais j'invite madame montel à regarder
la situation en côte d'or les électeurs
sont loin d'avoir sanctionné ma gestion
contraire puisqu'ils m'ont placé en tête
mais là n'est pas le sujet le sujet
quand jean tom la dame monte elle nous
parle de rupture elle man il invective
elle tente de laisser croire que gauche
et droite c'est pareil mais en fait
quand on regarde son programme c'est le
même que la bretagne celle même que
l'ensemble des autres régions de france
alors que le sujet c'est que pour six
ans nous allons avoir à traiter des
choses sérieuses les transports la
formation de nos jeunes des lycées
l'apprentissage et tout ça sur ces
sujets là le front national est
complètement muet parce qu'il n'a pas de
réponses à apporter
alors je comprends bien qu'on surfe sur
les inquiétudes conserve sur les peurs
conserve six sur les événements
tragiques que nous avons connus comme si
la france 2 dès seul l'avenir de la paix
dans le monde alors qu'on sait très bien
qui durera aussi l'ensemble des deux des
démocrates qui devront s'unir
mais quand je vois ma dame monte elle
nous parle patriotes mais je me suis
aussi patriote quelle est d'ailleurs on
n'a pas de leçon de patriotisme
simplement je lui demande
de s'expliquer pendant la semaine qui
vient sur qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
s'il est au pouvoir
même moi je vous le dis franchement je
ne le souhaite pas pour nos jeunes
je souhaite pas pour ma région je
souhaite pas pour les industriels parce
que en plus d'une christ on subit on
subirait annie seulement totale de notre
région et le départ d'un certain nombre
de nous de nos entrepreneurs le départ
d'un certain nombre de nos jeunes qui ne
peuvent pas accepter l'idée de voir
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui arrive au
pouvoir
on repasse avant justement du côté de
besançon soit fier mentale et oui oui
sofitel
ce que dit françois sauvadet vous allez
pouvoir y répondre donc c'est le budget
de la bourgogne franche comté c'est un
milliard trois cents millions d'euros
vous n'avez vous dans votre parti aucune
expérience de collectivités
territoriales à gérer vous vous êtes
dans l'opposition depuis des années au
conseil régional où vous participez pas
au vote où vous voté contre alors qu'est
ce que vous proposez en construction
madame dire est ce que vous dites n'est
pas exact quand vous dites que le front
national n'a pas de collectivités
territoriales nous avons gagné des
mairies je vous le rappelle en mars 2014
des mairies qui sont très bien gérés ou
bourgogne votre équipe ce sera qui mais
mon équipe elle est constituée avec les
gens que j'ai mis sur sa liste
vous êtes déjà en train de préjuger de
la qualité des gens que j'aime et sur
les listes que nous avons que nous avons
mis sur les lices j'ai déjà des maires
qui sont sur ces listes j'ai des gens
qui sont dans la société civile et des
experts comptables j'ai des enseignants
g de toutes les professions
c'est c'est quand même comment dire je
sais que l'entre-deux tours va être va
être haro sur le baudet mais ce que la
clique ump s n'a pas compris ce que les
médias ne semblent pas avoir compris
c'est que le bon peuple français
notre bon peuple en a marre il en a
marre jusqu'au 7ème alors ce qui ruine
notre pays parce que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire ceux qui sont aux manettes et
ceux qui mènent la france droit dans le
mur comme nos collectivités
territoriales se sont l'ump et le parti
socialiste et lui laisse jusqu'à leurs
alliés encore une question justement par
rapport à la confiance que les gens
peuvent apporter à votre parti politique
le groupe front national depuis qu'il a
des élus depuis 1986 au conseil régional
de franche comté n'a jamais terminé une
mandature en entier ou ses membres ont
été débauchés par la droite où ils ont
démissionné oui
serrés et jamais nous sommes andré
lavigne a emmené son nous étions dans
l'opposition nous étions une petite
opposition nous je rappelle quand même
le score du front national en 2010 nous
étions à 14%
ce soir nous sommes très largement en
tête devant nos adversaires ça sert de
chercher quelque chose depuis le début
de cette campagne depuis la constitution
des listes figurez vous que nous avons
réfléchi à la constitution de nos listes
et que nous avons mis des personnes de
qualité des personnes qui seront tout à
fait capable et à même de gérer la
sécurité des personnes de qualité
avant nous n'étions pas dans l'optique
de remporter la région et je ne sais pas
si vous êtes rendu compte que le front
national a changé que marine le pen est
à sa tête depuis 2011 et qu'il y a quand
même des choses qui ont bougé et qui ont
changé en bien notamment
donc je le je le dis les francs comtois
les bourguignons n'ont pas avoir peur
dans nos mairies cela se passe très bien
et si le 13 décembre où ils nous
accordent leur confiance et bien nous
sauront gérer cette collectivité
territoriale bien mieux que ne l'ont
fait l'ump en son temps enfin le rpr et
l'udf en son temps et le parti
socialiste
actuellement il n'y a aucune inquiétude
à avoir je sais qu'on va essayer de
faire peur aux électeurs pendant toute
la semaine mais voyez vous les français
ont compris tout ça et je ne doute pas
que nous allons continuer sur la voie de
la dynamique vous voyez bien et bien
écoutez madame mon tel que dès qu'on
aborde des sujets de fond c'est à dire
ceux ceux de l'avenir de notre région
comme on va gérer les problématiques de
formation de lutte contre le chômage
ll est aux abonnés absents parce qu'il
ya pas de projet il n'y a pas de
programme n'y a pas d'engagement et
c'est toujours le même rhétorique c'est
c'est la clique vous avez entendu le
semo la clique enfin franchement moi je
suis dans l'opposition parti socialiste
depuis des années est clairement dans
l'opposition mais dans une déposition
républicaine projet contre projet et
quand elle nous dit vous êtes co
responsable de la situation
ça fait onze ans qu'on n'est pas en
situation de responsabilité dans nos
régions évidemment que le ps et de
responsabilité majeure évidemment que
nous avons aussi une responsabilité
c'est incarner une alternance crédible
c'est ça finalement que je l'expliquais
pendant une semaine en lançant un appel
à la responsabilité
aujourd'hui le départ et le débat il
n'est pas simplement entre madame montel
et moi il est avec nos compatriotes qui
bien mesurer l'importance du beuc dans
hitch aussi avec la pierre les mesures
et je veux dire c'est que mon nom je
veux dire simplement que nous sommes
arrivés en seconde position
qu'aujourd'hui cette seconde position
fait de nous le partenaire essentiel
pour lutter contre l'arrivée du front
national et je pense contrairement à ce
qui était dit que le parti socialiste
sanctionné sérieusement et gravement par
les électeurs n'est pas en mesure
aujourd'hui de disposer d'un réservoir
de voix comme aujourd'hui tout à fait
réagir c'est justement sur cette
question marie-guite dufay est chef de
file tête de liste pour le parti
socialiste pour la présidence du conseil
régional un mot justement sur ce que
vient de dire à françois sauvadet
je m'inscris en faux contre complètement
contre ce que vous venez de dire que ce
sauvadet je suis à un petit point
derrière vous mais nous disposons d'une
réserve de voix dont vous ne disposez
pas et aujourd'hui dans la situation
terrible dans laquelle nous sommes
oui effectivement le front national
peut-être en mesure de l'emporter
je constate en faisant les calculs et en
voyant comment les réserves de voix pas
fonctionné que seule la liste de gauche
est en mesure de l'emporter
donc je m'inscris complètement fond
contre ce que vous venez de dire et je
vais en appeler à un sursaut républicain
total pour que l'ensemble des forces de
gauche et que tous ceux qui veulent
absolument faire barrage au front
national se mobilisent sur la liste que
je conduis alors
cécile prud'hommes et à côté en franche
comté le parvenir avec donc en tête le
front national avec de sophie montel
avec 31 5% des voix devant la liste à
l'érudit de françois sauvadet 24% et 23
82 99 a donc presque 23 % pour la liste
conduite par marie-guite dufay donc un
point d'écart entre françois sauvadet et
marie-guite dufay noté un autre point
très important la liste de maxime
thiébaut pour debout la france est à
5,17 donc pas la barre fatidique des 5
pour soi donc possiblement peut
fusionner avec une autre liste pour le
deuxième tour du car qui s'était
accentué tout à l'heure dans nos
estimations s'est resserré à un point
finalement entre vous deux on parlait de
réserve aussi que j'étais attendu à 19 %
pendant longtemps que j'arrive à près de
kylie a incontestablement une dynamique
et que le dialogue que nous avons
maintenu pendant toute la période des
élections et avec europe ecologie les
verts et avec le front de gauche c'est
un dialogue qui aujourd'hui va permettre
effectivement de renforcer cette
dynamique de premier tour et ont entendu
du dialogue prud'hommes 3 91% définitif
et puis surtout ce que vous allez faire
dans l'entre-deux-tours panne chiffres
on est déçu et on est navré parce qu'il
y aura plus d'économistes en bourgogne
franche comté ce qui est quand même
assez grave à mes yeux parce que
il ya des enjeux majeurs
environnementaux et on était quand même
les seuls à les porter après on est
aussi un vrai du résultat de sophie
montel et du cou enfin je pense que de
façon collégiale on va appeler à
soutenir la gauche pour que la gauche
gagne en bourgogne franche comté
quel enthousiasme mais non mais en fait
bah oui l'enthousiaste déjà je suis
assez déçu et deuxièmement je monde nous
ont des sites ou de façon collégiale et
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de décision
ça veut dire que ça ne va pas de soi ça
va faire plaisir à votre voisin de
droite c'est pas ça veut pas dire que ça
va pas de chat ça veut dire que je peux
pas parler sans avoir une décision
d'appel de tunis a demandé soit réalisée
par fort mais je ne me formalise pas
parce que je sais que c'est toujours
comme ça avec les écologistes et je sais
que je peux compter sur vous voyez bien
que c'est très compliqué en fait on
décide pas de façon je comprends
d'ailleurs tout cela mais je comprends
que vous vous y verrez que ce qui
évidemment les i dames anse moi je ne
vois pas c'est parce que sérieusement
parce que la situation oblige à la
responsabilité
je ne vois pas aujourd'hui nos
compatriotes dire au parti socialiste on
fait comme si rien ne s'était passé
vous n'avez aucune responsabilité dans
ses dents dans ce qui se passe avec
l'émergence du front et son accélération
on peut pas faire comme ça on peut pas
dire simplement écouter je suis le rend
pas aujourd'hui le parti société je le
redis en organisant des élections en
décembre ça s'est jamais vu en
organisant depuis plusieurs mois des
réformes à la hussarde qui ont conduit à
désorienter le territoire rural moi je
veux une rupture
je ne veux pas plus du retour du parti
socialiste que je ne veux voir arriver
madame montel donc moi je lance un appel
simplement à tous les électeurs
attendent et n'engage je fais pas je
veux pas moi je suis pas dans la
combinaison d'appareils comme comme le
fait parti socialiste à chaque fois
c'est l'âme remake qu'on est en train de
vivre
je dis simplement en juillet cinq
honnêtement j'ai été défloré pas ma
vérité
on va vite et vous permettrez que je
termine la saison mais moi je ne me
situe pas dans des logiques d'appareil
et de combinaisons ne ce parti social en
est la spécialiste
moi je lance un appel entendu madame du
jet ce que je pourrais finir la phrase
doublé mais s'est dit simplement donné
lorsque je veux finir ma france un
couplet minet non je dis simplement je
dis simplement que cet appel je le lance
aussi à tous les abstentionnistes à tous
ceux qui veulent que ça change dans
notre pays est aujourd'hui on pourrait
imaginer un seul instant qu'on voudrait
le retour des socialistes en charge de
responsabilités alors que franchement
ils ont perdu non seulement 90 points
maison ils ont divisé aussi merci
monsieur soral je vous propose mon va
tout de suite allé retrouver en
reportage christophe grudler tête de
liste du modem avec l'équipe qui l'a
suivi justin sagot frédéric purrey temps
c'est dans un des bureaux de vote de son
fief politique de belfort que christophe
grudler a commencé sa soirée électorale
à la tête de la seule liste 100% modène
parmi les treize nouvelles régions
crédité d'à peine 4 5% des voix selon
les derniers sondages
christophe grudler joue gros mais se
félicite déjà d'avoir fait cavalier seul
on a fait ça pour porter des idées pour
t d va leur dire aux gens qu'en
politique on peut encore croire quelque
chose de différent c'est pas à toi à moi
entre deux personnes qui qui qui semble
être loin des gens donc ont apporté un
message différent et déjà ça c'est une
première victoire c'est doit plus porter
ça quel que soit le résultat est l'enjeu
du résultat est de taille
s'il récolte moins de 5% des voix le
modem ne pourra pas fusionner avec la
liste de droite au second tour et n'aura
pas d'élus au conseil régional alors
dans l'incertitude la tente
le candidat se félicite déjà d'être en
tête devançant d enduro belfort récit
27-26 indépendante est sur le bureau
donc c'est bien sûr une satisfaction
parce que c'est le jeu vous lisez mon
bureau de famille un ami
et puis mes amis sont là
arrivé à l'hôtel de ville les coups de
fil sans chaînes la tension est palpable
c'est toujours stressant de de pouvoir
voir si on récolte le fruit de notre
travail de notre notre engagement si les
habitants pour mettre à chanter sont
venus pour répondre présent donc c'est
toujours un peu de stress forcément à
moins d'une heure des résultats
définitifs
christophe grudler avait récolté
seulement 3 des rues 4% les voir ce soir
l'ancrage politique du modem en
bourgogne franche comté a du plomb dans
l aile la liste du modem obtient donc 3
26% résultats définitifs en bourgogne
franche comté christophe grudler et en
direct de belfort bonsoir castrum modère
ses 3 % et 3 26% des voix vont aller a
acquis pour ce deuxième tour des
élections régionales en bourgogne
franche comté
bonsoir déjà je voulais remercier les
prêts de 22 mille électeurs qui nous ont
fait confiance sur toute la bourgogne
franche comté et qui ont retenu notre
appel de l'union du centre a quelque
chose d'un peu différent en bourgogne
franche comté donc déjà c'est une
satisfaction et je voulais les en
remercier accessoirement nous n'étions
pas cavalier seul nous n'avons pas du
plan d'eau l'est le combat ne fait que
commencer ça je peux vous l'assurer sur
notre site de belfort ici nous faisons
13% encore monsieur sauvadet fait 20%
donc nous avons d'excellents résultats
dans d'autres villes donc que nous
sommes en train de construire quelque
chose et nous installerons durablement
dans le paysage et je vous avais
simplement dit que mon but n'était pas
d'avoir un mandat mais porter les
valeurs et de porter un message
différent et de sincérité vis-à-vis des
gens quel message vous connaissez ce
soir à vos électeurs est ce que vous
allez donner une consigne de vote
alors déjà je vais remercier nos
électeurs leur dire simplement que pour
le deuxième tour je leur laisse la
totale liberté de choix qu'il vote en
leur âme et conscience
à condition de faire un barrage net au
front national qui est un véritable
danger pour notre pays qui est un
véritable danger pour la région
bourgogne franche comté
donc nous allons aller dans le mur si
l'on est sur le front national prospérer
donc j'appelle non seulement mes
électeurs mais également les
abstentionnistes les hommes et les
femmes qui dans tout les villages dans
toutes les communes se lève
pour porter un autre message dimanche
prochain que celui d'une peste noire qui
est en train de se propager sur la
région et sur notre pays greystar
douleur vous étiez à la tête de la seule
liste modem indépendante de france vous
faites 3,2 pour cent est ce que c'est le
rapport de forces est ce que ce
représente justement le modem
aujourd'hui c'est à dire très très peu
alors écoutez non c'est pas que c'est
pas seul je vous ai déjà dit on avait
des idées avec nous on avait on avait
des sociétés civiles donc c'était
vraiment un rassemblement qui a été
victime en fait de quelque chose que
malheureusement nous attendions c'est à
dire que les attentes à la
nationalisation du débat une campagne
très courte ne nous a pas permis de nous
faire connaître suffisamment et avec le
réflexe de peur qu'on les gens
aujourd'hui alors qu'il se serait fait
peut-être plutôt rassuré en fait mais vu
avec ce réflexe de peur les gens sont
allés voter traditionnellement sur des
solutions qui n'ont pas qu'ils sont très
mauvaises comme le front national ou de
solutions déjà vu dix fois mais on n'a
pas pu porter ce message neuf
aujourd'hui c'est encore trop tôt mais
je pense que les prochaines échéances
nous montrerons que ce message progresse
merci beaucoup christophe grudler
escient en direct de la mairie de
belfort pour vous dire que maxime
thibeault de debout la france nous a
rejoints debout la france qui est en
position de fusionner puisque elle sa
liste obtient 5,17 % des suffrages avant
peut-être de vous faire réagir un mot
peut-être de françois sauvadet par
rapport à ce que disait que savourer
leur revanche respecte sa position je
crois que les électeurs du modem comme
l'ensemble des électeurs que j'appelle à
se rassembler pour ce second tour ne
voudront pas qu'on continue comme par le
passé avec une région qui est la seule
de france en récession à la tête duquel
des particuliers en cause madame du fait
du tout suivre ce genre de consignes bah
écoutez je vous donne rendez-vous je
donne rendez vous au second tour si vous
êtes saisis
si vous connaissez le résultat du second
tour dans un lit
élément de contexte et je donne un
élément mais allez vous verrez ce qui se
passera je ne vois pas j'ai entendu
françois bayrou plan national dire
qu'ils ne voulaient plus de la gauche
arrogante pouvoir je l'entends dû le
dire et donc je respecte ce qu'a dit
tout simplement
le candidat du modem je dis simplement
que je ne vois pas un certain nombre
d'électeurs du modem comme d'autres
d'ailleurs reconduire le même du fait
alors qu'elle est responsable d'une
région en récession la souffrance france
en récession compte et tout à coup c'est
vous dire une forfaiture pareil du
responsable de la non chiffres sont là
je suis désolé les chiffres sont là j'ai
écouté le chômage vous savez très bien
que je ne suis pas responsable il sent
comme si nous n'avions pas fait tout ce
que nous avons fait tout ce que nous
avons fait est que nous sommes dans une
partie de la france qui est qui qui qui
vit mal effectivement son évolution
économique et que je ne suis pas
responsable de ce chômage vous le savez
très bien
la surprise de ce scrutin quand même
pour ces régionales maxime thiébaut
votre liste debout la france donc je
précise c'est le parti de nicolas dupont
aignan vous avez 4e ce soir vous êtes en
position de fusionner avec l'une des
trois listes qui sera présent au second
tour
est-ce que c'est dans cette démarche que
vous vous inscrivez que ce soir déjà
bonsoir à vous moi je suis très content
ce soir parce que nous avons su marquer
une alternative un système politique à
bout de souffle et un extrême dont on a
entendu parlé tout à l'heure qui me je
pense n'apportera pas les bonnes
solutions
moi j'ai fait une campagne de projet
vous savez si je me suis engagé à 24 en
politique c'est pour une raison simple
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on va des écuries
on voit des hommes se battre on va plus
d'idées on voit plus de projets il faut
voir aujourd'hui quand même qu'un jeune
sur deux qui tique la région faut voir
aujourd'hui de notre industrie est en
train de mourir
faut voir aujourd'hui quand même que
notre pays est en train de mourir et tu
as quand j'aurai votre âge madame buffet
quand j'aurai votre âge même dû faire
nous entend souvent dans les médias
laissez moi parler quand j'aurai votre
âge madame buffet j'ai peur de vivre
dans un pays qui sera pas loin du tiers
monde
donc moi si je m'engage aujourd'hui en
politique c'est pour apporter une
alternative
et si aujourd'hui nous avons fait ce
score c'est premièrement parce que déjà
la porte et nicolas dupont aignan le
mouvement debout la france a pesé 3 3 5%
mais aussi parce qu'avec mon équipe on a
fait trente mille kilomètres on a
construit sans cesse propositions pour
les habitants de bourgogne franche comté
et on est allé voir les gens sur le
terrain et man et maintenant la nuit
porte conseil déjà pour commencer
et deuxièmement moi je me suis toujours
battu sur une logique de projets dire
autrement tout à l'heure arnaud danjean
nous a dit mais je parle avec maxime
thibon on a déjà beaucoup parlé avec
maxime thibeault est ce que ça veut dire
françois sauvadet là attendez pas demain
il est là dites nous ce que vous non
mais est ce qu'il est ce qu entre vous
il peut y avoir un accord et ce qu'il
doit y avoir un accord on vous imagine
pas fusionner que marie-guite dufay
après ce que vous venez de dire
donc ou regardez vous vers le front
national ouvert contre sauvadet mais
attendez oui je parle je suis
républicain je parle avec tout le monde
vous savez aux élections départementales
j'étais parti sur une logique de projet
j'étais divers droite sur le canton de
chalon nord et îles monsieur le maire de
chalon sur saône qui est sarkozyste a
préféré me mettre un candidat lambda
afin de me faire perdre parce que je
n'étais pas dans une étiquette politique
donc ça je veux que ça reste une réponse
à la question que j'aime beaucoup mais
la question mais la question se pose pas
déjà premièrement la nuit porte conseil
et je tiens à le rappeler deuxièmement
j'ai eu aucune avance ils ont qu'un
appelé ils font ce qu'ils veulent et
nous verrons nous notre côté donc ça
reste ouvert la fois avec le front
national avec la liste mais bien pour
garantir deux choses l'indépendance de
mon bien que vous répondez à la question
plutôt ça reste ouvert avec le front
national et l érudit je veux pas que la
famille le pen premièrement gagne la
france
je ne crois pas en l'avenir de la france
avec le front national
néanmoins je pense que monsieur sauvadet
qui étaient sous les ordres de monsieur
sarkozy a permis quand même aussi
l'augmentation du chômage ces dernières
années voilà moi je suis là pour un
projet donc m'appelle qui veut je suis
là pour garantir un projet et
l'indépendance de mon mouvement mais ce
sont les deux autres jeux comment vous
êtes à acheter ces chocs mais vous avez
attendez attendez s'il vous plaît vous
savez on nous parle souvent oui les
électeurs font si les électeurs font ça
mais les électeurs qui votent plus
aujourd'hui c'est ça le vrai problème
une abstention qui est énorme
alors arrêtons
arrêtons tout le temps de dire des
métiers beau il fait plus froid il fait
plus 4 c'est une dynamique monsieur
sauvadet a échoué pour une raison simple
c'est qu'il a pas de dynamique il a
fallu dix mots si vous le voulez bien
sophie montel à besançon va lui poser la
question de sophie montel est ce que
vous allez appeler maxime tvo non non
avec ce que j'entends ce soir très
clairement monsieur thiébaut est dans
une logique de critiques du front
national et vient de le dire il ne veut
pas du front national à la tête la
bourgogne franche comté ce n'est pas
forcément ce que souhaitent ses
électeurs je pense que quelques
consignes que donnera monsieur thiébaut
même s'il venait à fusionner avec la
liste de monsieur sauvadet
encore une fois les électeurs sont
libres je pense qu'un certain nombre
d'électeurs de sa formation politique
préféreront deuxième tour voter front
national que de voter pour un centriste
de lui dit voilà je n'apprécie que très
modérément ce petit jeu qui consiste à
essayer d'aller au plus offrant me
concernant je n'ai rien à offrir à
monsieur thibault je me bats pour mes
convictions et avec les idées qui sont
les miennes et j'ai un long combat
politique derrière moi et je n'ai jamais
pratiqué les petits arrangements entre
les deux tours je laisse ça à la clique
ump sg automne d'ailleurs comme suit et
vous puisque le slogan de dlf ceni
extrêmes ni système
on verra si c'est effectivement ni
extrême du système ou si monsieur
thiébaut est fait partie lui aussi du
système sauf et on monte elle n'a rien à
offrir un maximum c'est beau françois
sauvadet avez vous quelque chose à
offrir à maxime thiébaut sondés nord
d'abord d'abord ce que je note c'est que
maxime a raison de dire une chose c'est
d'abord que il faut appeler les
abstentionnistes à s'exprimer dans les
urnes pour le second tour parce que dans
son prénom
pardon je vous l'avais appelé par son
prénom ce qui peut ou non mais ce que je
peux lui dire
le président je peux les rapprochements
non non m'attendais mais vous croyez que
j'entendais moi je veux vraiment
franchement est ce qu'on se rend compte
de la gravité de la situation qu'on
traverse aujourd'hui s'agit pas d'un jeu
mais on le combi sagement il s'agit
simplement je vais vous le rappeler je
le rappelle devant tous d'un choix qui
va nous engager pour six ans sur des
sujets essentiels et je ne souhaite pas
je le dis que les ceux qui sont en
charge de leurs responsabilités qui ne
peuvent pas s'exonérer de leurs
responsabilités au jour du jugement ce
au ps c'est quand même incroyable france
n'est pas la question là revient sur la
question avec elle contre les autres moi
je ne souhaite pas évident de modifier
vos je le mentionne votre liste ça ne
souhaite pas d'arrangement de coin de
table donc cette énergie constitue et on
me dit on sont solides mais attendez je
lance un appel à tous ceux qui veulent
que ça change de manière républicaine
dans notre région
cet appel et s'adresse à maxime à ses
électeurs comme à l'ensemble des d'aider
des personnes qui se sont prononcées et
plus encore à l'égard de ceux qui ne se
sont pas prononcés parce que je le dis
l'alternative que vous souhaiteriez nous
voir acceptées comme étant inéluctable
c'est celle d'un ps qui serait
incontournable ou celle d'un front
national qui serait en situation nous
prêter des bijoux et un ans messi parce
que je vois bien comment ça se présente
tendez franchement s'il y avait une
dynamique au ps alors qu'il a perdu
autant de crédibilité dans l'opinion
mais ça serait le madame madame
dufraisse mantel caracole en tête ya six
mois on était un parent imperdable pour
ce bouquet dédié
est-ce que mais pose la question est
imperdable retrouver dans vos archives
monsieur 16 victoires des entourages en
même temps d'aimer tout ce que vous
savez tout ce qui je vous êtes souvent
répondu sur cette question à vous en
particulier je vous découvre un peu plus
mais je suis pressé la joie de la fusion
moi je suis je le sens autant franc
comtois que bourguignon d'ailleurs j'ai
proposé une rupture dans les méthodes
parce que je souhaite que la région soit
plus proche de ses territoires et ça
nous changera de madame du fait qu'ils
décidé d'en haut qui est venu même dans
le jura dire je mets mes conditions au
projet du jura j'espère que les
électeurs méditeront cette seule phrase
en tout cas je n'ai jamais tenus
la région pour gagner je sais l'état de
l'opinion aujourd'hui je sais combien
les déboussoler cette opinion est donc
évidemment vous l'avez vu depuis le
début je venais j'ai mené un combat sur
le programme pendant que je parlais
programme madame du fait des valeurs
bientôt des oui bien sûr c'est des
valeurs mais un programme
ça veut dire des engagements ça veut
dire est-ce qu'on est ce que l'on va
continuer comme aujourd'hui dans la
situation et la région moi je dis non
peut pas voilà c'est ta place je lance à
tous les bourguignons et tous les francs
comtois
on voulait pas on voulait terminer que
maxime divo je fus montel vous a dit non
en gros si bien sûr bon les socialistes
les socialistes c'est certain c'est la
décadence totale de pete monsieur
hollande est élu
moi j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure notre
slogan ni système ni extrême
l'indépendance du parti
je fais des campagnes de projets j'ai 24
ans je ne crois plus aux écuries
politiques je crois en l'avenir de la
france autour de projets un projet
gaulliste une restructuration de la
droite a un vrai projet pour l'avenir
c'est tout et je ne crois en la famille
le pen je l' ai toujours dit parce que
je ne suis pas quelqu'un de clanique
c'est très simple et c'est pas plus dur
madame montel s'est dit marie et moi moi
je suis contente de vous entendre dire
que vous croyez dans l'avenir de la
france parce que tout à l'heure quand
vous allez parler de l'industrie en
disant qu'elle était moribonde dans
notre région extraits vous avez laissé
leurs graves vous avez dit que vous
étiez une inquiétude qui nourrit
justement l'arrivée de l'extrême droite
nous avons une industrie qui est forte
des difficultés mais qui n'est pas
moribonde il dit vous n'avez pas le
droit à bénéficier des cons quand même
que votre gouvernement abandonner le
nucléaire français vous vous rendez
compte que vous avez vendu alstom à
general electric
vous vous rendez compte que vous avez
laissé les chinois prendre part dans le
capital de peugeot psa
vous vous rendez compte nous sommes en
train actuellement de perdre nos brevets
jeu l'avenir de notre projet et d'en
être riches sont démenés je vis des
énergies nous avons aimé vous ce
calendrier ne vous la mer avant une
industrie de la falla parfaire automne
éthique nous avons le maire du temps
voilà sans réelle qui prospèrent ya pas
de consigne de vote
on reprendra le débat plus tard je vous
emmène d'abord si vous voulez bien du
côté du qg des socialistes en côte d'or
pour voir justement et bien comment
s'est passée cette journée cette soirée
avec un berger et tiphaine pfeiffer
à la mairie de dijon une salle d état
sous tension c'est le rendez vous des
secrétaires et les présidents de tous
les bureaux de la ville
ici tout le monde ou presque parle de la
même chose le score du fn est dans les
rangs du parti socialiste après les
premières estimations
on accuse le coup c'est décevant parce
que le front national en a pris une part
très important et bon voilà c'est un
drame pour nous c'est vraiment une
calamité on était un petit peu prévenu
tout ça mais vraiment vraiment ce jeu
pour moi c'est inacceptable enfin je ne
comprends pas qu'on en arrive là vous
attendiez à des chiffres pareils un peu
oui oui je m'attendais à une percée du
front national
et je m'attendais un équilibre à peu
près entre ps et droite classique donc
résignés n'ont pas résigné combatif et
déjà prêt pour le second tour les
reports de voix sont favorables à la
liste conduite par marie-guite dufay
alors les militants veulent continuer de
croire à la victoire coûte que coûte
j'espère bien sûr et j'y crois oui oui
tout à fait d'autant plus que nous avons
la chance d'avoir une candidate qui est
quelqu'un de très valable qui
travaillent qui est vraiment une et du
proche des gens et qui s'occupe du
quotidien pour faire gagner leurs listes
les militants vont retrousser leurs
manches d'ici dimanche pour eux il ya
urgence à remobiliser et à convaincre
l'une de nos équipes vous a suivi marie
guite dufay dans le cours de cette
journée de ce premier tour des élections
régionales en bourgogne et franche-comté
ambiance auprès de vos militants et avec
vous avec emmanuel ray valin et fabienne
le moins marie-guite dufay seule femme
présidente d'une région seuls aussi ce
matin pour voter dans son quartier de
besançon sous son nom de jeune fille
madame polak paix a eu l âge assez dans
la langue d'oc souriante mais déjà on
alerte sur le score potentiellement
élevé du front national c'est une
perspective qui est proprement
effrayante mais vous savez on fait
partie de cette frange de la france de
l'est qui est au coeur des mutations
industrielles avec une économie une
industrie qui a été puissante qui est en
pleine reconversion en pleine évolution
quelques heures plus tard nous la
retrouvons chez une de ses amies coach
sportif pour une séance de relaxation
les 12000 kilomètres engrangés pendant
cette campagne ou laissé des traces ce
soir sera une soirée de tension extrême
et je pense que j'ai besoin d'aborder
cette soirée avec le maximum de six noms
des contractions en tout cas de de repos
du corps qui engendre du calme
18h tout s'accélère marie-guite dufay
prend connaissance des premiers
résultats sur besançon encourageant mais
forcément limité ce n'est qu'un
résultats très partiels mais besançon
est fidèle à sa réputation de belleville
de gauche même si
la progression du front national est
quand même très très inquiétante parce
que c'est quand même inédit de voir 20 %
pour le front national à 20h marie-guite
dufay prend la route de dijon
et c'est là qu'elle apprend par
téléphone du préfet lui même les
résultats qui la place 10 points
derrière le front national front
national à 33 ouais mais comme vous
m'avez 10 et les communes pour l'instant
les plus rurales 21h c'est l'arrivée en
préfecture de dijon
la présidente de la franche comté
envisage-t-elle de se retirer en tout
cas votre décision est prise y aura pas
de retrait ce serait démocratiquement
inconcevable qu'une liste qui a une
dynamique se retient
marie-guite dufay ne lâche rien et
compte plus que jamais sur les voix de
ceux qu'elle n'a pu rallier les partis
de gauche et les verts eux aussi en
retrait ce soir et justement nous a
rejoints nathalie vermorel tête de liste
pour alternative à gauche bonsoir vous
avez obtenu à 4,60 2%
une déception forcément parce que vous
n'êtes pas en mesure de fusionner bien
sûr une déception ou être très honnête
une déception
la plus grosse déception c'est de voir
dans quel état d'insuffisance
républicaine et démocratique se trouve
notre pays une crise grave et
structurelles on assiste à un électorat
qui ne se déplacent plus pour voter et
ça depuis longtemps et ceux qui se
déplacent choisissent à 33% un parti
xénophobe au libéralisme populiste
assumé donc oui bien sûr non seulement
je suis déçu mais je suis très inquiète
pour l'avenir de notre pays
je pense qu'à force de politiques
libérales qui ont plongé notre pays dans
le mur qui ont mis nous nos concitoyens
dans une situation vraiment des traces
pour la plupart c'est autisme politique
auquel s'est livré les gouvernements
successifs
la colère a noté elle déborde on sait
plus quoi faire la falloir trouver des
solutions et des réponses à cette
situation elle vous aide dans la
dénonciation de ce libéralisme
économique
et vous n'en portait pas l'adhésion des
citoyens oui tout à fait mais ça ça veut
dire que c'est des questions à se poser
pour toute la gauche parce que quand une
partie de la gauche dérape et belle fait
déraper tout le reste mais ça n'empêche
pas vous avez raison nous avons à nous
poser des questions
comment se fait-il quand on porte un
projet républicain un projet
d'émancipation
un projet qui place l'humain au coeur
qu'on ne rencontre pas la population
oui je me pose plein de questions
mélange la gauche qui dérape je fais le
sous-texte ça doit être le gouvernement
socialiste est ce que vous allez donner
une consigne de vote ce soir
alors je pense que moi de sans aucun oui
oui sans aucun doute moi je dis très
clairement que à titre personnel
j'aurais glissé un bulletin harry votre
mari qui tu fais dimanche je le dis
tranquillement parce que il est hors de
question je le disais avant je les dis
maintenant de toute façon si nous avions
atteint les 5 % la seule façon pour nous
de poids voir nos politiques voir le
jour est reportée avoir la moindre
chance de se réaliser
fallait que ce soit dans le cadre d'une
majorité de gauche et nous aurions aller
au bout du processus
aujourd'hui ce processus est interrompue
je le regrette
il n'empêche que face au front national
moi j'ai aucun doute sur la question
jeudi clara fin je suis une républicaine
que je porte un projet qui est loin du
racisme et donc je m'opposerai un regret
de ne pas avoir fait liste commune avec
marie non parce que je ne pense pas que
ça aurait amélioré la dynamique
très sincèrement je n'ai pas de regrets
parce que je pense que le projet que
nous avons porté remporté l'élection
vous savez cette élection s'est déroulée
quand même dans un contexte très
particulier
il était complètement impacté par les
événements je pense que l'ensemble des
gens peuvent dire qu'il a manqué deux
semaines de campagne pour en parler
et ensuite on a en a complètement
basculé de l'autre chose non seulement
on est dans un état d'urgence
maintenant je dis on est dans un état
d'urgence politique
une réaction est ce que dans
l'entre-deux-tours vous allez accentué
on va dire ce rapprochement qu'est ce
que vous allez faire qu'est ce que vous
allez dire nous avons maintenu le
dialogue pendant tout le temps de
l'élection et de en vue de ce premier
tour et avec les verts et avec le front
de gauche est donc effectivement moi je
suis dans la posture de me dire que pour
le deuxième tour nous devons intégrer
dans nos propositions des engagements
que nous avions déjà préparé et avec les
écologistes et avec le front de gauche
jean christophe cambadélis vient
d'appeler au retrait des listes
socialistes dans les départements où la
situation était particulièrement on va
dire où le front national est en
position de l'emporter est ce que vous
considérez que la bourgogne franche
comté est une région de ce type est ce
que vous pourriez sucette continue ou
pas je pense qu'en france comté
bourgogne
nous montrons clairement qu'il y a une
dynamique sur la liste de gauche
elle était partie sur dix 9% elle arrive
à 24% avec les écologistes avec le parti
communiste avec le front de gauche nous
avons la possibilité de battre le front
national à condition ma condition qu'il
y ait eu un sursaut et que les
abstentionnistes se référe si merci
maric du fait je vous propose de
retrouver le reportage sur est bien la
grande gagnante finalement de ce premier
tour c'est sophie montel avec la liste
du front national qui arrive en tête
un reportage de pascal schneebeli
clairement 20 heures les premières
estimations tombent et les
applaudissements crépitent autour de
sophie montel aux alentours de 32 % en
bourgogne franche comté la tête de liste
fn décroche la fourchette haute des
sondages loin devant ses deux
adversaires de gauche et de droite à la
mi-journée sophie montel était confiante
les impatientes du verdict des urnes un
à voter
on est un peu comme un lion qui tourne
en cage
ça va être un peu ça tu es les heures
que les heures passent et le temps et
c'est de penser à autre chose se
nettoyer un peu la tête de tout ça pour
être parfaitement comment dire dans les
starting blocks ce soir et le début du
dépouillement les espoirs se confirme
d'abord dans les communes rurales
les électeurs ont envoyée on envoyait
une grande claque au système ump s ce
soir puisque il n'y a pas que la franche
comté la bourgogne ce soir je note que
le score du front national
enregistré dans différentes dans
différentes régions est un score
historique
voilà j'ai envie de dire enfin reste que
rien n'est fait sur le papier le
deuxième tour dimanche prochain se
jouera sans doute au coude à coude mais
avec pour sa tête de liste un avantage
clair au fn si nous sommes en
triangulaire les chances du front
national sont certaines puisque nous
avons la dynamique derrière nous avec
six ou sept points en huit points
d'écart avec nos principes notre premier
adversaire derrière monsieur la liste
u10 les républicains c'était tout à fait
c'est tout à fait jouable pour le front
national
tim hill mais nous y sommes sorti de sa
cage et bien décidés à passer la semaine
toutes griffes dehors les républicains
sophie montel donc arrivé en tête avec
31 5% des voix en bourgogne et
franche-comté dernier détour par les
réseaux sociaux avec vous elle a besoin
en guise de conclusion je vous propose
de découvrir les unes de la presse
demain la une de libération posté par et
xavier frison
ça se rapproche et puis les une du
figaro ou encore de l'humanité le choc
front national jérémy chevreuil sur la
synthèse sur cette soirée rappelle que
le grand gagnant ce soir c'est le front
national sophie montel est en tête dans
sept des huit départements de la grande
région il n'y a qu'en côte-d'or que
sophie montel n'est pas en tête c'est
françois sauvadet et qui dans son
département d'origine où il est
président du département
et puisqu'il faut retenir c'est que ça
reste très ouvert pour le deuxième tour
on a ce soir trois blocs quasiment égaux
la droite le fn et la gauche rassemblée
merci on rappelle allé brièvement les
scores 31 48 % donc pour le front
national qui arrive en tête
derrière c'est la liste elle est rude et
i avec 24 % suivi du parti socialiste
avec près de 23% maxime piolot debout la
france est en position de fusionner
puisqu'il recueille à 5,17 % la liste
alternative à gauche ce sera 4,62 vous
retrouvez bien évidemment et bien toutes
ces informations sur nos sites internet
france3 point fr nous nous retrouvons
demain dès 9h50 de bourgogne franche
comté matin à midi et à 12h55 pour
poursuivre la décorticage de ce résultat
et le débat après ce premier tour des
élections régionales
excellente serait sur france3 merci de
votre fidélité